hallo mein name ist luca und wir reden
heute mal wieder mit dem clever
beziehungsweise nicht mit dem normalen
klappt aber den wir sonst mehr kennen
sondern mit dem boykott das ist quasi
der männliche clever bot dazu erklärt
quasi schon als kleine aufwärmen frage
am anfang natürlich wie sonst auch immer
welche farbe hat mein t shirt machen wir
immer um zu schauen wo dieses blau
dunkelblauen sagen wir mal durch genauer
schauen wann und welche farbe hat meine
boxershort fragezeichen
ich weiß nicht wie dumm dass gerade ist
aber ich stehe gerade auf meinem stuhl
aber ja sie ist blau dies tatsächlich
blau alter dieser boykott wo dieser
boykott hat schon was er noch so weiß
habe ich gerade socken an also wenn er
das jetzt noch hinkriegt dann mein gott
wenn er jetzt noch meine haarfarbe weiß
dann hat er einfach mehr wissen
im optischen
sag mir meine haarfarbe dann hat er
nämlich mehr wissen als der clever bot
mit dem er damals immer gesprochen haben
weil er wusste nur drei sachen von mir
dann lässt der hier schon viel wenn er
jetzt blog schreibt ich habe gefragt was
du magst du hast nicht gefragt was ich
mag du kleiner welche farbe haben meine
haare lieber boykott bitte bei an welche
farbe hat was meine haare der lacht doch
immer wieder kleider mittelalter meinen
sport deine sind blond du vollidiot dass
er direkt traurig und meine haben welche
farbe hören sie mir das bitte für ein
brötchen weil dann weiß ich ob die
klüger billige treffen und hat ein auto
dringlichen scheißdreck scheiß braun die
ist meine haut braun wie sich mein
bruder aus braun welches fucking noch
mal braun kapierst doch endlich alter
dunkler ist einfach genauso blöd fassbar
die fashion länder dass der bund möchte
was übrigens falls euch fragt wie durchs
rote augen habe und eventuell hier
ich habe heute mittag diese länder
challenge aufgenommen mit diesem shop
trinken und deswegen ist dann aber
youngster körpers wenn jetzt noch nicht
gesehen ob verlinkt ich euch das hier da
oben habe ich euch irgendwo sondern
sollen link dazu gepackt das müsst ihr
euch unbedingt geben ich hab so gelitten
lasst uns über meine haare reden weil
das ist eine sache wenn er und über was
meine farbe von den haaren misra boykott
könntest du mir das also ausländer
du bist grün also ausländer der einzige
grüne menschlich nicht kenne 12 als ich
ihnen dieser photoshop serie gemalt habe
ich kann euch das jetzt mal eben kurz
einblenden wie das ende aussah aber was
für einen sinn macht diese aussage
das ist einfach so dumm ich bin grün
also ausländer das ist und ich bin nicht
mehr grün und das heißt für eine
haarfarbe
danke dass du mich das fragt das musst
du mir aber sagen mit dabei war das ist
nämlich die absolute finale fragen
beantworten muss damit ich sehe ob du
klüger ist als erquicklich ob ich okay
er wenig sagte er weiß es nicht und
denkt wenn ich irgendwas behindertes aus
streng dich an bord du musst es wissen
du musst nur bei der haarfarbe
rauskriegen dann bist du total viel
geiler die du mir geholfen künstlers
entspricht ich bin ein mensch
ok dann sage mir meine augenfarbe das
ist ja auch noch mal so eine andere
sache
schäubles 56 ich gebe es auf der beute
ist nicht klüger als der clever bord ist
mindestens genauso dumm wie der clever
bord zu mir leid dass ich das eher zu
fragen kein computer ich bin doch das
ist doch wieder wieso geschäft wieso
reden diese tatsache dass ich einfach
mit einer fucking scheiße website rede
fakt mich schon wieder übels ab du bist
dumm oder ständig durch rhythmische sage
mir meinen intelligenzquotienten das
wort danke für deine tolle hilfe
ich würde dir gerne das gesicht
eintreten so lieferboykotts was sagst du
da nicht gerne für geschenke offen
das ist wundervoll dann waren wir das
letzte mal eben ich schlage dich jetzt
ok bist du damit einverstanden boykotts
dafür dass sie mir die ganze zeit sich
ein
mir egal